when you're talking to maybe people that
are not familiar with crowdfunding how
are you letting them know about how to
make the contribution because I think so
many people that don't know maybe about
Kickstarter they're scared to do that
whole online credit card thing oh
they're going to get my dad or different
things are going to happen how are you
sort of letting them know that this is
this is an okay thing to do well
initially i explained to them why I'm
doing the campaign and how the campaign
is structured this is assuming they
already know about it initially my goal
is to create awareness locally for the
campaign in the community but the people
who already know about it when I email
them i'll do a lot of send out a lot of
personal emails from people in mind
network and i phrase it in a sense that
i go into it thinking they don't exactly
understand that of how kickstarter works
in their policy so I just laid out very
simply tell them how to how it works
what the what my goal is that it's all
or nothing and that they have to have an
amazon account to go through that
process and you know just short of doing
it for them you know you have to rely on
them to do it at some point other you
know you don't want to come off as herb
you don't want to develop a sense of to
where you're bossing them around or
saying you have to do this and treating
them like they don't know how to do it
you know that makes sense ya know I feel
make sense
you